well for more than a month now
supporters of illegal immigration in the
state of Oregon have decided to halt the
enforcement of immigration law by
harassing the people who are tasked with
enforcing it
activists engaged in an Occupy ice
protest at one of the agency's
facilities in Oregon they finally
laughed but they left a gigantic pile of
garbage to remember them by here it is
where protesters once stood trash now
litters the property next to the ice
building on macadam protesters left this
behind
work trucks packed to the brim with
everything from food to furniture
cardboard signs and wooden pallets
a trimet official told Fox 12 workers
even found needles on the ground
Karen Witten attended and slept
overnight at the occupy ice camp in
Portland he joins us tonight Cameron
thanks a lot for coming on
Tucker's good to see you again so it's
nice to see you
so is this a foretaste of what we can
expect if the revolution actually
happens so you guys take over and leave
piles of garbage why would this reassure
anybody watching at home that activists
like yourself should have any power over
anything thank you for that question so
first what I want to do is celebrate
this successful display of grassroots
people powered change what happened here
was occupy ice both here in Portland and
across the country sent a powerful
message about the economic and
humanitarian crisis that has been
created by families separation and other
harmful immigration policies we garner
the support of former first ladies and
we're able to write no I know the US
president to change a part of a
draconian immigration policy and there's
congratulations dimension Cameron I know
you're excited about this hold on
why couldn't you use that people power
you're telling me about to pick up the
garbage before you left how does that
work you mobilize you've got a mass
movement right of engaged people who
want to make America better but you live
beer bottles and hypodermic needles
behind yeah is that really that kind of
change most people don't think so
because can we
right now about interest of American
sheep uh conversation why not afford why
are we here wouldn't a conversation
no-show addresses this topic more often
and more directly than this one does but
I'm an American I was born here I have a
family okay I don't want to live in a
place that looks like two goose egg Appa
and you I don't I don't think anyone in
anyone does including immigrants mhm and
I'm just saying if you are sitting a
model for the rest of us why the hell
were you living like animals it's that's
a totally real question what's the
answer and then we'll move on once you
answer it how's that so we are living in
a time of crisis in the United States
and I am so thankful that there are
people who are demanding change and you
know what you what we're dealing with
right now is a crisis and we cannot sit
here and cast blame for certain
individual actions you cannot take
certain individual actions and then
dismiss why we are here
stop it's tracting from the message that
imagines that we are right now is the
question I want to read okay okay but
this is central to the point no no let
me talk to you in your terms you're
telling me you're making let's say you
have an annual family barbecue and your
brother-in-law shows up drunk do you
cancel the whole barbecue no so we're
talking right now is that there was a
protest where people weren't this
camping outside people across the
country story they were not a mystery
case we're talking about the message of
this minute and hold enforcement and
Trump look everybody and I'm sure that
you don't agree with everything serves
everybody their actions what they say
regardless of why we are here
and we cannot ignore the fact that
Superman changed and we have to do
traffic stops making me
your choice and I've just I can't handle
it okay
thanks Cameron I don't think you did
yourself for your cause any help at all
but maybe you did maybe there's someone
watching you think you know that that
Cameron guy the guy left all the beer
bottles and the hypodermic needles I
like him I'm on his side down maybe
there's someone like that call me if you
exist